بين هجوم روسيا وهجوم مضاد اوكرانيين حرب
موازيه لم تهدا عالميه كفتها رجحت منذ
البدايه لاوكرانيا الكريم اليوم يعاني من
فرض روايته حتى داخل روسيا نفسها اعتقاد
لاستمرار
الصوتيه دون صوره وانتقاد لتقارير الحرب
التي يتلوها ايغور كونشينكو وصفت بانها
صوره مفصوله عن الواقع روسيا حضرت كل
القنوات الغربيه لديها واقرت قوانين رادعه
لكل لكل من ينتقد العمليات العسكريه
والمعارضه وصفه الخطوه بفرض اساليب القرن
العشرين على اعلام العصر الجديد في
المقابل اصطفت وسائل الاعلام الغربيه وراء
اوكرانيا واغلقت ابوابها امام داعيم موسكو
اما في اوكرانيا تحولت الدعايه الى مشروع
قومي التقطه الشعب
حسابه وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه على تويتر
خير ومثال يديره خمسه خبراء هدفهم الاول
ضمان تناسق كل المقاطع الخاصه
مع ابعاد المكان والزمان هذا الفيديو مثلا
موجه لبريطانيا الحان الموسيقار الانجليزي
هوسكو ستوف وفريق ذا كلاش مع اقتباسنار
الاصدقاء يبكون اصدقاء لكن مخاطبه
الاليزات تختلف جذريا عرضا لمعالم باريس
ترافقه موسيقى
وفي النهايه يقدم الطلب على طبق من
الرومانسيه طلب مدافع سيزار معركه اخرى في
الرياضه في الوقت الذي تطالب فيه زخرفه
يوميا عن حق بلادها في المشاركه في
اولمبيادت تعمل ثياب على فرض رايها بطريقه
مختلفه